الى فقره الدراما وهذه المره حديثنا راح
يكون عن الدراما الكوريه التي فرضت نفسها
بقوه خلال السنوات الاخيره ووسعت قاعده
جماهيرها في المنطقه وتقع في فخ التنميط
الهوليودي تجاه العرب على ما يبدو هكذا
يرى المغردون على تويتر الذين انتقدوا
الحلقه السابعه من مسلسل ملك الارض او
كينج افضل لاند واتهموا صناع العمل بتعمد
الاساءه لصوره العرب وطالبوا الشركه
المنتجه بالاعتذار والذي قام بالدور
المثير للجدل هو الممثل الهندي انوبام
احد ابطال المسلسل لعبه الحبار سكويد جيمز
وقام بتجسيد شخصيه امير عربي ظهر وهو
يغازل البطله لجذب انتباهها وينفق بلا
حساب وهو ما اعتبره الجمهور صوره نمطيه
متكرره تقصد تشويه الثقافه او التشويه
الثقافي للعرب
وخفضوا تقييم المسلسل على مختلف المنصات
في دفاعها قالت قناه جي تي بي سي التي
تعرض المسلسل في بيان قصير ان جميع شخصيات
والمواقع والاسماء الموجوده في الدراما
خياليه تماما
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم ملك الارض ليس العمل الكوري
الاول الذي يثير غضب الجمهور العربي في
2017 اضطر صناع مسلسل مانو دايس تو ليف
للاعتذار عن التصوير المسيء للثقافه
العربيه والاستهزاء بمشاعر المسلمين في
اكثر من مشهد وبالنسبه للامثله في هوليود
واحدث ولا حرج عمل 2006 هددت حكومه
كازاخستان بمقادات الممثل البريطاني
بعد صدور فيلم بورات ومنعت عرضه لانه
يتناول صحفي كازاخستاني يعطي صوره سلبيه
عن بلاده عند زيارته لامريكا فيلم جاكي
شانور والذي حقق نجاحا ساحقا عند عرضه
ازعج الكثير من الامريكيين الاسيويين بسبب
النكات العنصريه على اساس العرق والصور
النمطيه المهينه تجاه الاسيويين بحسب
رايهم اخيرا دعا العديد من سكان الاصليين
في امريكا الى مقاطعه الجزء الثاني من
افاتار خلال العام الماضي على اساس انه
يستولي على ثقافتهم ويضع السكان الاصليين
في قوالب نمطيه عنصريه
شيرين طالبه جامعيه كوريه جنوبيه تدرس
اللغه العربيه يتابعها عبر انستقرام
ويوتيوب نحو 700 الف مستخدم معظمهم من
العرب تحاول شيرين من خلال مقاطعها
التقريب بين ثقافتين الكوريه والعربيه
وتتنوع موضوعاتها بين التعليم الكوريه
لمتحدثي العربيه والسياحه الترفيهيه
وتقييم افضل المطاعم وغيرها في عام 2021
منحتها الملحقيه الثقافيه بسفاره السعوديه
في سيول المركز الاول في مسابقه اللغه
العربيه للالقاء والكتابه ايضا وفي اول
العام الجاري كانت سلطنه عمان اول محطاتها
في الدول العربيه تجربه اقتربت فيها اكثر
من المنطقه وعادتها شيرين معنا اليوم
مشاهدينا للحديث عن ازمه المسلسل الكوري
وايضا الجدل الذي احدثه المسلسل بين
الجمهور العربي
والكوري انا بس قبل ما نبدا بالمقابله سمر
يعني عن جد انه هذا شيء مجحف جدا دائما
ببينوا على قلبه هوليود العرب يا اما ثري
جدا يا اما ثري جدا ومبذر يا اما ارهابي
واحنا هذا شيء لا يشبهنا ومش بشكل كبير
بحقنا يعني اذا من سيول تنضم الينا
المؤثره وصانعه المحتوى الكليات شيرين كيم
تفهميني باللغه العربيه صح لما اكلمك
باللغه العربيه
نعم نعم ممتاز ممتاز مرحبا صباح الخير
تشرين من فضلك بدايه
تحدثين اكثر عن سوء التفاهم الذي حصل او
هل هناك نوع من التقصد لاظهار صوره العرب
بهذه
النمطيه او بهذا الاطار
صراحه بنسبه لي انا كشخص كوري انا ايضا
منصدمت كثيرا بعد ان شاهدت هذا المشهد
الخاص الذي يصبحها جدلا كبيرا في علم
العربي في المجتمع العربي وللاسف ليس جميع
الكوريين يرون ذلك المشهد مشكله كبيره جدا
بل اغلبهم يقبلونك يعني
نعم هل هذه الصوره النمطيه التي
ظهرت في دراما كوريه هل هي ماخوذه من
هوليود لانه شفنا هذه الصوره النمطيه في
افلام ومنتجات
واصدارات هوليود يعني بشكل كبير على مدى
سنوات طويله هل هذه ايضا نظره الكوريين او
فكرتهم عن العرب معقول
يمكنني ان اقول نعم يعني اغلب الكوريين قد
يفكروا بهذه نفس الطريقه
لان اصلا يعني في الواقعه
المعرفه والمعلومات عن ثقافه العربيه
والاسلاميه في كل
ضعيفه يعني صعب صعب فهمها
ومعرفتها اذا لم ندرس عنها بشكل جيد لان
لا يوجد لدينا فرص كثيره لتعلمها فكل ما
يشاهدوا الجمهور الكوري
عبر مثلا الاعلام او الانترنت هذا هو كل
شيء ما يشوفه علم العرب او ثقافه
الاسلاميه
فرغم انهم لا يوجد لديهم مثلا نياده سيئه
للعرب فيعني ما اعتبروا عن سوره سوره عن
العرب اصبحت سيئه بالتاكيد
العالم العربي
وللاسف
لذلك هناك اعداد اقل مما كان متوقعا من
الكوريين الذين يشيلون الى هذا الجزء
الخطا باعتباره جدل ويقولون انها مشكله
كبيره
طيب انت جيتي للعالم العربي وتعلمتي اللغه
العربيه هل لك ان تخبرين انه كيف تغير
نظرتك الى العالم العربي قبل ما تتعرفين
علينا اقرب وبعد
قبل ان نتعلم اللغه العربيه واهتمت
بلغات العربيه وثقافتها انا لم اكن اعرف
عن الدول العربيه والاسلاميه ايضا بشكل
جيد حتى بعد ان تعلمت عنها يجب علي ان
اتعلم اكثر
وكان لدي ايضا بعض الافكار الثابته عنهم
عن ثقافه العربيه والاسلاميه لان انا ايضا
كنت منهم من الذين يشاهدوا الاعلام فقط
ويفكروا عن الافكار الثابته عن العالم
العربي هو كل شيء في الدول العربيه
والاسلاميه ولكن بعد ان تعلمت وليس فقط ان
هناك الكثير من الكوريين يتعلموا اللغه
العربيه وثقافه العربيه
ايضا
بنفس الشيء مثلي ولذلك انا وليس فقط انا
بل هناك الكثير من الكوريين يرون هذا
المشهد مشكله كبيره كبيره
يجب عليهم ان يغيروا طريقه اخراج
المسلسلات يجب عليهم يفكروا اكثر قبل يعني
بعتقد يا شيرين هذا
وهكذا بعتقد شيرين بانه يعني انت ربما احد
المؤثرين في هذا الموضوع بما انه انت عندك
صفحات على مواقع التواصل فيها متابعين
كثير يعني ان شاء الله بس اغلب المتابعين
عرب ان شاء الله يكون في عندك متابعين
كوريين لحتى تساهمي في تغيير هاي
النظره النمطيه للعرب انا حبيت اسالك وين
تعلمتي عربي اين تعلمتي العربي
نعم تعلمت اللغه العربيه
للمره الاولى لما كنت في المدرسه الثانويه
بدات تعلمها بنفسي لان ارى شخصيا ارى
الحروف العربيه واللغه اللغه العربيه هي
لغه مميزه جدا وانا شخصيا احب اتعلم
اللغات الاخرى فبدات تعلمها في منذ 2015
هكذا ثم دخلت الجامعه التي فيها تخصص
اللغه الدراسات العربيه لتعلم اللغه
العربيه وثقافه العربيه اكثر طيب اسالك
شيرين احنا للاسف اولادنا نفسهم ما
يتكلمون عربي مثل ما انت تتكلمين كم ساعه
باليوم يتطلب الامر لدراسه لغه يعني كليا
خارجه عن ثقافتك وعن مكانك وعن لغتك كم
ساعه تطلب الامر من الدراسه والتعب لتتقني
اللغه بهذا الشكل
انا
كل يوم مختلف طبعا انا لا اعلم بالضبط
ولكن كل يوم ما افعله هو قراءه اللغه
مثلا اي شيء اي كلمه عربيه بالانترنت مثلا
بعد انا فتح سوشيال ميديا وارائكم
وتعليقات باللغه العربيه رغم اني لا افهم
ما معنى تلك التعليقات وحاولا اقرا
نعم اهتم بالنطق العربي ايضا سوف نطقك
ممتازه الحقيقه يعني وانت تتكلمين العربيه
بطلاقه
جميل جدا يعني
وننتظر زيارتك للدول العربيه عنا هون في
استوديو العربيه حتى نتحدث اكثر ان شاء
الله
نكهه عربيه مختلفه غير مش بس اللغه ولكن
الثقافه ايضا شكرا جزيلا
شكرا
السلام عليكم انا تشيري كيف حالكم ان شاء
الله تكونوا بخير اليوم سوف اقوم بتصوير
المقطع عن اللغه الكوريه وفي المرض
الماضيه قد تعلمنا عن الحروف الكوريه
وتفاصيل لقد تعلمنا الحروف الساكنه
وللحروف العله وكذلك تعلمنا ان عندما نكتب
اي كلمه باللغه الكوريه يجب ان نبدا من
حرف الساكن اولا وبعد ذلك نكتب
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات